okay hi everyone my name is 'more I'm a
PhD student at tel aviv university and
clinical psychology resident and i was
invited here today in order to tell you
a little bit about using machine
learning in psychotherapy research these
are some of the wonderful people working
with me on this amazing project so i'm
gonna start with a very basic question
me at least who believes that
psychotherapy actually works that going
to a psychologist helps okay this is a
little better than i expected
but for those of you who didn't raise
your hands i think you kind of have a
solid point because for me as a
researcher and as a psychologist i can
tell you i deal with this very question
myself every day and we don't have a
clear answer yet
so i'm gonna spend the next nine minutes
telling you why this is a very
complicated question and what can you do
in order to fix it so in a therapy just
like in other medical fields we have to
show that a certain procedure has
actually led to a good outcome and in
our case that paying 400 shekels to your
lovely psychologist every week is
actually working promoting your health
the probably is that unlike biology we
don't have blood tests or microscopes
and this is a problem because we have a
really it's really hard time to measure
it
it also requires dealing with natural
language which we all hate because this
is probably the most complicated thing
on earth especially for us and this is
why currently most psychotherapy
research is actually based on going to
people and asking them how they felt
after the session which let's be honest
it's not very scientific so one day we
had a thought maybe we can use this
complexity in our favor instead of
fighting it and this is why we have
invented the matrix the matrix is a
contact analysis scheme for
psychotherapy
he transformed session transcripts
everything being said during those 50
minutes in two sequences of code using
an algorithmic and objective menu every
sentence during the session gets a
three-letter code that gives you 150
codes per session and if you take
hundreds of sessions from different
patients you get what we can pull Big
Data and this is a place where
complexity is kind kind of a blessing so
this is the matrix with a flow it's a
very basic table with two axes but I'm
going to show you that everything being
said during a therapeutic session can
actually be possible within these nine
boxes
so the first X is called focus it is
basically asking who is the sentence
about it could be either the patient the
therapist or both of them we call it a
diet it's a fancy word the second axis
is called a mention it is basically
asking what is this sentence about and I
like to think about it like music
potential is like a musical scale he
tells you what notes could potentially
exist within these skills in our case
experiences this is not the actual
experiences but the ability to have them
and this is probably the most common
reason why people come to see me because
they want to experience more things the
second one is called content which is
the experience itself it's like a symbol
note a memory a dream feeling and the
third one is called interrelation which
is like the melody several notes placed
one after the other creating a specific
song but not other in the human mind
it's like a conflict and this is in a
real session the patient and therapists
are talk and you can see how these
sentences transform into very very
simple code the first letter indicates
the speaker either the patient or the
therapist the second one
is the focus who about and the third one
is the dimension what about and at this
point we can say goodbye to the text and
move into the world of machine learning
so what are we doing with this very
fancy table if we zoom out for a moment
we see that the bait the matrix is
basically and restore such a larger
process aiming at designing and making
better and effective treatments in order
to do that we first need to move from
session audio to text and then from
metrics codes right now we have actual
human coders one of them is sitting
right over there you can touch it they
it takes hours and hours on each session
and this is why we are currently working
on a pencil developing velopment
platform that will enable Selina
automated metric if we are successful
that means that I can compute the actual
speaks in math you actually understand
how we organize our mental experiences
the Signum of the arm of the project is
heavily based on machine learning
basically we want to ask can we predict
the model the ideal session can we
predict the outcome of an entire
treatment based on a single session on
its codes alone and lucky for us we have
a close collaboration with the levels of
Fatih in the openness it II she brings
us cutting machine learning methodology
that could do some magic with their
codes and I want to show you a little
example of this kind of test that we do
last year we gave the computer 2000
metrics codes
kind of a small database and it was
taken from good and poor outcome
treatments computer was in you tell us
about these sessions we believe that
organization must have something in
common the unique fingerprint and one
way of approaching it was to use a
finite state machine model which is like
asking what is the ideal
sequence of code given very set of code
what is the most active way into a
successful treatment and we figured that
breaking in code this as you can see
right you that letter change must have a
meaning because it means that the
patient and the therapist are not in the
same page there are not congruent the
patient he taught that talks about one
thing and his therapist about another
and that can be good and that the
conference ratio of the session which is
how many congruent moments were as
opposed to how many breaks involve could
actually depreciate in 100% between good
and true outcome treatments and as you
can see when when the converse ratio was
low the work all over the place at the
world from one box to another on the
other hand when the currency rate was
high high all code were in the same box
and it's either also associated with
four hours of treatment this is why if
we look at that new session you see
that's the code is mostly congruent but
there's some occasional breaks that
think that we have a good alternative
activity for us this is kind of
mind-blowing because it means that if
you give me a random session from any
treatment have to tell you that a little
bit about the option for you to see this
regional diversity or its purposes about
what the symptoms are which is kind of
Awesome and here you can see that we
wanted to check that it's not only
associated with treatment outcome but
can also predict it and as you can see
in four parameters see that the coolest
by reading fountain and fYI such
findings put the future be worth
billions of dollars in the US alone
because this is how much failed
psychotherapy cost every year
and what can we do with all this
information we want to help Tara do the
very complicated jobs and this is our
vision of what we call a clinical
dashboard it's a tool that allows our
therapies to get an immediate analysis
of the session understand what happened
and and they do better in order to
improve it for the next one
users could easily record the session
and restore it we can also provide them
some information about the converse
ratio of the session as we know now that
it predicts better outcome we can also
point a user to hotspots moments during
the session where the code was broken
and negatively fully studied before the
next one and such insights we hope could
possibly win psychotherapy research into
the 21st century thank you
[Applause]